okay let's talk about a few other things
that happened this weekend some of them
are 9 11 related you know rudy giuliani
was the mayor of new york city when 9 11
happened and
there is certainly
debate about the degree to which rudy
giuliani handled 911 properly
but there is no question that he was
experiencing a very solid and healthy
approval rating at the time he was seen
colloquially as america's mayor and i'm
not saying i agree with him on all
policy but he had a high approval rating
and was relatively well respected
that has gone into the toilet over the
years as he has gotten more and more
involved with donald trump and then
really embarrassed himself regularly
with all of the voter fraud stuff and
appearing on television seemingly drunk
multiple times a charge which he has
denied but he's continued holding this
annual 9 11 dinner
the 9 11 dinner this past weekend
went completely off the rails with rudy
giuliani showing up apparently so drunk
that he was making no sense and slurring
something he might do not drunk also
we're not making fun of alcoholism we're
merely just again stating the fact that
this is a guy who's been put in
positions of significant power and
responsibility
and he may not be
he may be lacking the capacity for it
partially because of what seems to be a
drinking problem
many reports about they would try to
keep rudy off of nighttime television
because it was more likely he would be
drunk and so on and so forth and we're
going to look at a couple of clips and
it just just the degree to which this
guy has fallen from grace is insane
business insider reporting video
captures rudy giuliani's rambling speech
at a 9 11 dinner in which he
impersonated queen elizabeth ii yeah
rudy gave a rambling speech at his
annual dinner the former mayor
impersonated queen elizabeth said he's
never socialized with disgraced prince
andrew giuliani also described how he
wanted to grab general mark millie's
awarded stars and shove it down his
throat
um
let's just get right into the video
clips okay
this is
this is rudy this was broadcast on real
america's voice
it's all wacky
can imagine tony blanken or miley
[Applause]
how's that guy a general
jesus
the other day he said that the bagram
air force base is not strategically
important
i want to strategically grab this what
do you have five stars 10 stars 12 stars
he has so many stars coming up into his
ears
i wanted to grab his stars shove it down
his throat and say it's 400 miles from
china [ __ ]
china is going to be our enemy for the
next 40 years
you have an air base 400 miles from them
and you're giving it up idiot right
what
i like the one guy yelling right in the
audience hell is wrong with you
who paid you
christ
that is crazy
i don't know
i shouldn't get into this what biden did
in the last two weeks is freaking insane
it cannot be explained
[Applause]
yeah well
28 years ago
i did my job for the country
i'm very proud of it
but i did it because of them
but bernie
demonstrated to you i was so happy he
did
it this is it is sad more than anything
right you can't show everybody right you
can't show look
every one of them would like to show you
the 10 people
that supported them
right espo
right joe right
you're going to do it on your own how
many people did you have helping you
i had denny i had tony
my howard
i had joe
phil was in the mail room and a lot of
people
talk where's tony
i'm out of these people that were with
me
really really strange stuff and then uh
eventually he went into his queen
elizabeth impression
and it if you can imagine it got even
more weird
she said you did you you did a wonderful
job
on september 11
and therefore i'm making you an honorary
knight
commander
of the
royal something rather
i turned down a knighthood because if
you took a knighthood you had to lose
your citizenship
i know prince andrew is very
questionable now i never went out with
him
ever
never never had a drink with him
never was with a woman or a young girl
with him whoa what
making a lot of denials unprovoked
aren't you rudy
one time i met him in my office and one
time when we had the party right bernie
you were there yeah okay anyway so rudy
giuliani really just an embarrassing
fall from grace
rudy giuliani recently said he doesn't
think he's ever done an interview drunk
doesn't think but he did say i drink
normally like scotch i drink scotch he
also said i'm not an alcoholic i'm a
functioning
i probably function more effectively
than 90 of the population and whether
that's a freudian slip where what he's
saying is he's a functioning alcoholic
or just that he functions really well
not really clear but just a very sad
state of affairs for rudy giuliani i
think it's time now with the 20th
anniversary to retire these 9 11 annual
dinners they've gotten just a little bit
too off the rails and if we end up
hearing anything about rudy and prince
andrew certainly that would be
interesting given his completely out of
the blue denial there
one of our sponsors is nebia who have
developed the most impressive shower
head i've ever seen it was designed by
former nasa engineers who spent years
researching how to save water and what
they created the nebia bimon spa shower
uses 45 percent less water than a
traditional shower head but with an 81
percent more powerful spray and they do
this by using atomized droplets that
rinse soap and shampoo off faster than
any shower head i've ever used i
installed nebia by moan spa shower in my
bathroom at home took five minutes to
set up i've been using it for about a
year
i'm in and out of the shower way faster
because of that powerful spray but again
it's helping the planet and your wallet
by using 45 percent less water than a
traditional shower head the nebia by
moan spa shower starts at just 199 but
you'll get 10 percent off all nebia
products when you go to nebia.com pacman
and use the promo code pacman the link
is right underneath this video